[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8 lipdo
votre émission qui revient sur
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines
au sommaire ce vendredi 21 février cela
avait été annoncé en juillet 2019 la
possibilité de payer ses impôts facture
et taxes locales chez son buraliste
la pratique est lancé dans les semaines
à venir dans dix départements dont les
yvelines
quinze ans après la loi pour l'égalité
des droits et des chances la
participation et la citoyenneté des
personnes handicapées
le président de la république emmanuel
macron fait de nouvelles annonces et
interpelle les candidats aux élections
municipales pour se saisir de son sujet
nous jouerons avec nous en plateau un
élu du conseil départemental des
yvelines 2 ap air france handicap
le salon de l'agriculture ouvre ses
portes ce week end et les ébénistes sont
bien présentes
les chiffres de la délinquance dévoilé
est un jeune yvelinois titulaire pour le
match de rugby france pays de galles en
équipe du vin ou feront autour de ce qui
a marqué d'essentiel de l'actualité
cette semaine
payer ses impôts et ses factures
administratif chez son buraliste ce sera
possible dès le 24 février dans certains
bureaux de tabac des yvelines
le département est le seul
d'ile-de-france a testé le dispositif
avant son extension au 1er juillet dans
tout l'hexagone
reportage réalisé avec jules cachan et
pourquoi pas une facture d'imposition
dès lundi des buralistes de dix
départements offriront la possibilité à
leurs clients de régler imposé facture
administrative à l'aide de leurs bornes
française des jeux bien sûr nous étions
plusieurs sur les rangs
dont la poste mais nous avons donc
réussi à l'obtenir dû aussi à notre
maillage et un autre amplitude horaire
avis d'imposition factures de cantine ou
de crèches amendes de stationnement il
suffira de scanner son document est de
régler le tout aux buralistes avec un
maximum de 300 euros en espèces une
démarche supervisé par la direction
générale des finances publiques
cd tabac qui ont qui ont signé le
contrat avec des équipes et qui ont fait
la formation parce que on vous lance pas
endetté d'argent pour l'état sans avoir
eu une formation avant les buralistes y
voient un moyen de continuer de faire
rentrer du flux malgré la hausse du prix
du tabac mais côté clients on est
dubitatif façon moi je prépare internet
c'est plus vite et c'est plus simple
sauf que c'est pas là c'est pas très bon
de promener toutes ces informations
voilà ça reste dans un cadre limité à
chacun c'est chacun son rôle
tabac les timbres les jeux après un si
on commence à leur donner plus de
travail
si le test est d'abord effectué dans
quatre bureaux de tabac du département
au 4 mars sauront 106 pluraliste des
yvelines dans 60 communes qui
proposeront ce service avant son
extension à toute la france en juillet
la fédération des buralistes estiment
atteindre les 2 millions d'encaissement
par an
[Musique]
je veux d'abord ici lancer un appel très
solennelle nous sommes dans un contexte
et je crois que c'est ma fonction mon
rôle de le faire celui des élections
municipales
je veux ici lancé un appel à tous les
candidats et les engager à penser dans
leur programme la commune inclusive sans
laquelle il n'y a pas de société
inclusive
c'était la semaine dernière le 11
février date anniversaire de la loi dite
handicap de 2005
le président de la république emmanuel
macron a convié plus de 400 personnes
pour une conférence nationale du
handicap
il y a fait plusieurs annonces comme une
hausse de 90 euros par mois de
l'allocation adulte handicapé et une
reconnaissance du droit de vote pour les
majeurs protégés et dit vouloir faire
entrer la société dans une philosophie
nouvelle considérant les personnes en
situation de handicap
donc comme une altérité mais bien des
citoyens à part entière et vous l'avez
vu il interpelle les candidats aux
élections municipales à se saisir de ce
sujet dans leurs programmes créés sur le
lièvre vous êtes avec nous dans jours
jours alors vous êtes élu au sein du
conseil départemental de apf france
handicap l'association dans un
communiqué a salué des avancées mais
aussi des manques importants alors
qu'elles sont ils ces annonces et c'est
manqué évidemment j'aurais dire que la
grand messe est dite
elle attire le regard sur les personnes
en situation de handicap et cette
conférence et un focus à mon sens
intéressant pour comprendre que les
personnes en situation de handicap et
elles ont besoin d'être re regardé comme
les autres tout simplement
voilà nous sommes de plus en plus
nombreux en france a présenté des
particularités on va dire à savoir 20 %
de la population
moi je pense aux femmes enceintes je
pense aux mamans avec des poussettes je
pense encore aux malentendants aux non
voyants
je pense aussi et j'ai entendu ça
l'autre gens ça m'a beaucoup plu aux
musicologues ceux qui ont un casque sur
les oreilles qui sont en situation de
handicap parce qu'ils partent ne
perçoivent plus de leur environnement et
ils sont aussi soumis à des problèmes
d'accessibilité parce qu'ils ne voient
pas ils ne perçoivent pas leur
environnement voilà il ya aussi les
fauteuils roulants naturellement les
handicaps invisibles qui
ne se voit pas mais qui malgré tout
présente des difficultés pour les gens
qui en sont victimes
voilà et puis on oublie pas le grand âge
en fait puisque on est une population
vieillissante en français on se rend
compte que il ya quand même de plus en
plus de monde alors toutes ces personnes
quelles qu'elles soient
elles ont toutes le même problème si on
peut dire c'est l'axé l'accessibilité en
fait des lieux publics l'accessibilité
de la voirie qui se dégrade de plus en
plus dans nos régions voilà alors
emmanuel macron a notamment demandé des
efforts concernant le scolaire avec pour
objectif aucun enfant sans solution de
scolarisation à la rentrée et à la
rentrée 2010 neuf là ils étaient 8000
dans cette situation alors pour cela il
préconise l'augmentation et la
valorisation des accompagnants
quelle est la situation actuelle à
l'écouté la valorisation et
l'accompagnement des enfants c'est une
très bonne chose mais il faut aussi
penser qu' il faut que nos écoles soient
accessibles
je me suis porté volontaire avec la
ligue des droits de l'homme pour faire
de la sensibilisation au handicap dans
des écoles et en fait je me suis heurtée
à un problème très simple c'est que je
ne pouvais pas accéder à ces écoles en
fauteuil roulant donc on veut accueillir
les enfants en difficultés je comprends
mais si les connais pas accessible c'est
la double peine en fait c'est un
effectivement l'accompagnement de
l'enfant et de l'accès à l'école n'est
pas forcément adapté par tous alors
justement en termes d'accessibilité sur
ce point manuelle macron renvoie aux
élus locaux et aux candidats aux
élections municipales les saisir est ce
que c'est une bonne piste d'une part
saisir les candidats aux élections
municipales c'est une bonne chose
sauf que au delà de ça il faudrait et
c'est le cas dans ma commune où on a
trois listes municipales sur lesquels on
a on voit trois candidats qui sont en
situation de handicap je pense que c'est
une très bonne chose de se saisir de ce
sujet en état en intégrant donc ces
personnes avec ses particularités de
façon à faire en sorte que on démontre
que on veut faire une société inclusive
on veut se donner les moyens de dd en
fait toute la population puisque si on
permet aux personnes en situation de
handicap d'accéder à différents endroits
de la commune que ce soit au niveau de
la voirie des bâtiments publics et des
salles de spectacle et du reste on va
appeler ça de la qualité d'usagé pour
tous et je peux vous dire que quand il
n'y a pas de trottoir pour franchir un
seuil quand il n'ya pas d'escalier bien
personne ne tombera dans l'escalier
compris les bien portants
est ce que les actions en cours dans le
département justement pour interpeller
les candidats alors la paix est france
handicap a mis au point à un plaidoyer
donc à l'attention des élus et des
candidats aux élections municipales
donc dans lequel on relate toute la
problématique effectivement de l'accès à
l'école de l'accessibilité dans
l'environnement de la ville vous avez
évoqué les salles de spectacle justement
je veux faire un mot concernant la
culture
la députée yvelinoise aurore bergé a
rendu un rapport sur l'émancipation par
les arts et la culture en début de
semaine 60 propositions pour une culture
pour tous
et parmi elles certaines concernent le
handicap par exemple la nomination dans
chaque maison départementale des
personnes handicapées mdph un référent à
la culture développer la programmation
de spectacles adaptés aux déficients
visuels et auditifs avec des objectifs
chiffrés créé sur le lièvre ce qu'il ya
beaucoup à faire justement sur la
culture
déjà moi j'entends que les qui est un
référent
culture dans les mêmes des ph ça me ça
m'interpelle pourquoi pas sauf que les
mdph n'ont déjà pas le temps de traiter
les dossiers qui leur sont confiées en
sachant que ils ont quatre mois pour
répondre à un dossier et on attend 1
attend facilement huit mois dans les
yvelines pour solder un dossier ld ph
look si on y ajoute la culture on va
écouter je pense qu'on va peut-être
faire reculer les délais je pense qu'il
ya pas assez de personnes dans ce
service pour pouvoir répondre aux
attentes de l'ensemble des gens qui
déposent un dossier
voilà en ce qui concerne la culture est
bien intégrée intégré ou faire en sorte
que les personnes en situation
d'handicap puisse exprimer quelque chose
au travers de la culture jeu ça me
paraît tout à fait intéressant c'est ça
va dans le sens d'une vraie société
inclusive quelque part ou marque pas la
différence en fait voilà on peut très
bien faire un spectacle avec son
fauteuil roulant ou avec d'autres
difficultés comportementales
on a vu un spectacle à
verneuil-sur-seine ya pas très longtemps
ou c'était une troupe qui venait de
belgique donc pour faire un spectacle
l'ensemble de la troupe était avec des
troubles divers et variés mais ils ont
fait un spectacle et ça ça a donné
quelque chose d'absolument reichshoffen
pour tout le monde et on s'est dit ben
oui finalement ils sont différents mais
ça aussi ex prison aussi quelque chose à
exprimer qui nous touche et qui nous
fait grandir non parce que passer par la
culture serait une manière de
sensibiliser la culture est un moyen
comme un autre de deux d'épanouissement
en fait je pense qu' un individu quel
qu'il soit qui se cultive trouve
une forme d'épanouissement et je pense
que quand on est en situation de
handicap on doit pas être exclue de 2 du
bénéfice du de l'épanouissement en fait
non dans les cultures
alors n'en veut dire un peu haut à l'un
des trois objectifs des manuels macron
qu'ils aient une vie digne et libre
permis à tous on est complètement dedans
une vie digne et libre
excusez moi mais c'est ça une ligne
digne et libre
une vie digne et libre de la latinité
bien entendu que tout le monde aspire à
la dignité compris les gens en situation
handicape la liberté elle ne peut à mon
sens exprimé que à partir du moment où
on peut aller partout on souhaite aller
au niveau des transports en commun avoir
des transports adaptés pour certains
parce que on ne peut pas faire autrement
des transports qui soit aussi fiable
l'accès aux salles c'est aussi une forme
de liberté l'accès à l'école c'est une
forme de liberté l'accès à la culture en
est une alors pour conclure quelles sont
les actions menées par apple france
handicap
actuellement ou à venir mais les actions
que l'on mène en ce moment donc c'est à
l'attention des maires effectivement
pour les interpeller pour pouvoir pour
leur permettre de s'imprégner en fait
des situations de handicap et puis de de
penser dans leur programme une société
inclusive en fait tout au fait de la
vraie qualité usages saas est une chose
et puis autrement nous à la pf en france
handicap on a interpellé par des parts
des cas particuliers de personnes de
parents d'enfants qui souhaitent
intégrer leurs enfants à l'école
d'accessibilité de centres commerciaux
qui sont prometteurs mais pas adapté
voilà et puis nous avons aussi un
mouvement puisque les déclarations des
manuels mâcon sont ce qu'elles sont mais
on considère que la comment on va dire
la mission n'est pas complètement rempli
donc la bf france handicap doc au niveau
de l'île de france va organiser une
journée donc le 5 mars place d'italie à
paris devant le siège de l'ap et france
handicapée il va y avoir un parcours de
la place d'italie à bastia le 5 mars
donc un parcours en fauteuil roulant ça
va être épique mais c'est intéressant à
voir
non merci christian de liège est revenue
sur notre plateau jura peuvent être élus
au sein du conseil des yvelines 2 ap et
france handicap
on perçoit reste de l'actualité de la
semaine
[Musique]
une année 2010 9 encore marquée par
l'augmentation dès violences sexuelles
tout comme les escroqueries le ministère
de l'intérieur a communiqué les chiffres
de l'insécurité et la délinquance pour
l'année 2019
plus précisément dans les yvelines vous
le voyez sont en augmentation des
tentatives d'homicides les viols ou
encore les vols de véhicules par rapport
à l'année 2018
al'inverse les cambriolages les
infractions à la législation sur les
stupéfiants sont en baisse et cette
information révélée par les fps
la fp en début de semaine un entraîneur
historique du club d'athlétisme de
l'ouest 78 a été suspendu le 4 janvier
dernier par la préfecture des yvelines
une enquête préliminaire a été confiée
au commissariat de saint-germain-en-laye
suite à plusieurs dépôts de plaintes
pour harcèlement moral harcèlement
sexuel et viol commis sur un mineur de
plus de 15 ans pour des faits
susceptibles d'avoir été commis entre
2004 et 2010 9 on ouvre maintenant une
large page agriculture et environnement
événement annuel incontournable le salon
de l'agriculture ouvre ses portes ce
week end
christophe robin s'occupe de la ferme de
la une hier à son chant et sera présent
sur le stand du mouvement à gré demain
manon par aldo a rencontré cet éleveur
de volailles sur son exploitation
christophe robin est agriculteur depuis
2012 à la ferme de la une hier suite au
départ en retraite de ses parents en
il prend les rênes de cette exploitation
c'est un éleveur passionné j'ai pris
l'habitude de prévenir les volailles
quand même quand on arrive dans le
bâtiment et éviter de le stress aussi à
la ferme de la hunière des poulets
fermiers sont produits dans ce bâtiment
d'élevage 600 volailles sont présentes
dans ce 80 mètres carrés
on a tout réorganiser l'espace
l'ensemble des bâtiments donc la
prochaine étape ça va être de mettre une
porte dans le fond ici dans le pignon
qui sera automatisé dans son
exploitation à son chant christophe
robin fabrique l'aliment des volailles
avec les céréales de la ferme et ans
cultivateur jeu produit à la fois du blé
et du maïs que c'est la base de
l'aliment des volailles cet agriculteur
prend soin de ses volailles qui sont
bien en chair alors les amis ça va là
dedans avec une durée d'élevage entre 90
et 120 jours pas semaine prochaine je
vais en emmener un petit peu au salon de
l'agriculture pour fournir le stand
hagrid mince époque vivent là on avait
dû 3 qui l'occupera kilo vif
christophe robin fait partie de ce
mouvement qui rassemble plusieurs
exploitants afin de lutter notamment
contre la grille bashing une certaine
méfiance à l'égard du monde agricole
il va falloir continuer à nourrir une
population est grandissante satisfaire
les besoins en bien-être animal et en
production de qualité et de proximité il
faut réussir à faire revenir les gens à
la ferme qu'ils aient qu'ils aient en
visu ce qu'on fait pour avoir un lien
avec ses consommateurs l'agriculteur se
rend au marché de clairefontaine en
yvelines
christophe et damien met en place les
produits de la ferme de la une hier ses
8 90 le prix attention je t'ai c'est la
plaquette
si tu as un but sur quoi que ce soit tu
prends la plaquette l'éleveur maîtrise
90% de la production de la filière
seules les parties abattage et des
coupes sont délégués les consommateurs
ont pu déguster les produits de la ferme
et parfois repartir avec c'est le nôtre
que vous voulez christophe robin sera
présent mercredi 26 février sur le stand
à grille demain du salon de
l'agriculture s'est produit aussi
allez bon dimanche madame
[Musique]
et à cette occasion du salon de
l'agriculture la présidente de la région
ile de france valérie pécresse annonce
est quatre priorités priorités pour ce
secteur en 2020 plus de détails avec nos
confrères via grand paris convertir
l'agriculture francilienne au bio c'est
l'une des priorités de la région
ile-de-france valérie pécresse a
présenté ses objectifs pour 2020
aujourd'hui trente mille hectares
franciliens sont cultivés en agriculture
biologique
c'est trois fois plus qu'en 2015 le
pacte écologique signé en 2018 doit
encore permettre d'accélérer en jeu
quarante cinq mille hectares cultivés en
une menace le désengagement de l'état
l'état supprime ces aides
alors que va faire la région et bien
toutes les aides supprimés par l'état la
région va les remplacer
donc nous allons nous substituer à un
état défaillant sur le bio pour que les
agriculteurs bio qui se sont engagés
dans cette démarche qui ont fait les
investissements c'est très lourd de la
transition bio et bien ne soit pas en
insécurité et pour qu'on garde cette
formidable dynamique de transition vers
l'agriculture biologique
autre priorité de la région développer
les circuits courts en rapprochant
citoyens et agriculteurs une centrale
d'achat va être mise en place pour
fournir les 463 lycées d'île de france
avec 100 % de produits franciliens dont
50 % de bio d'ici à 2024 14 produits
déjà identifié les carottes les pommes
de terre les lentilles les pommes les
poires la baguette des franciliens mais
aussi la volaille les oeufs la viande
donc vraiment et la banane des outre
mers parce que la balle à l'antillaise
nous la considérons comme un produit de
circuits courts en ile de france
autre défi assurer la relève des
agriculteurs et surtout rajeunir la
profession aujourd'hui un agriculteur
sur cinq a plus de 60 ans nous
travaillons évidemment avec les jeunes
agriculteurs
nous avons fait un site avec qui promeut
le les métiers de l'agriculture nous
avons une agriculture qui est encore
très familiale en ile de france et on
veut la garder
donc ça suppose de d'encourager tous ces
jeunes agriculteurs à s'installer à
prendre la succession
leurs parents de leurs familles et puis
aussi d'attirer des nouveaux et ça aussi
c'est l'homme l'objet de notre plan de
formation depuis 2016 4200 formations
ont été financés par la région ile de
france
et pour clore cette page environnement
je vous propose d'aller à la rencontre
de nicole depuis 12 ans elle sauve des
crapauds et autres tritons le long des
routes
une action qui a permis d'accroître la
population batracienne dans la forêt de
gan b reportage - vallée de chevreuse en
cette saison des amours les batraciens
rejoignent leurs points de natal pour se
reproduire
seulement à gambais l'étang de la
bruyère est séparée de la forêt par une
route
alors depuis 12 ans nicole s'occupe
d'eux à l'aide des lycéens du chef de
tremblay sur mauldre et d'autres
bénévoles elles disposent des barrières
de 140 mètres de long financé par la
commune de gombe et et le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
afin d'empêcher les batraciens de se
faire écraser les arrive effectivement
de la forêt ni vont longer la bassée à
un moment ils vont tomber dans le faux
et chaque matin jusqu'au mois d'avril
des bénévoles viennent ramasser les
batraciens des sceaux pour les faire
traverser en toute sécurité
si nicole a commencé seule avec son mari
et son fils
au fil des années d'autres amoureux de
la nature l'ont rejointe comme aymeric
il s'est arrêté il allait la boulangerie
rappel et il a dit loeb à l'année
prochaine vous me contacter
je viendrai vous aider
voilà c'était contacté alors de alors je
note amman chaque batraciens et
répertoriés pour prouver l'efficacité de
la démarche
il y à 12 ans 500 animaux ont été sauvés
cette année les 6 ramasseurs espère
dépasser les 2500 127 crapauds mâles
dix neuf femelles et trois triton palmé
ce qu'il fait 149 batraciens sauvé
aujourd'hui fort de leur réussite les
bénévoles ont demandé un système plus
pérenne de bâtera co d'uc soit des
tunnels sous la route dédiée donc le pnr
tout à fait d'accord sur sa faim en camp
qu'on a déposé le dossier contacté le
pnr se dit sensible à la démarche mais
le terrain est en complexe les études
hydrographique doivent être menées elles
auront lieu courant mars
le nouveau ministre de la santé olivier
verrons a consacré l'un de ses premiers
déplacements à la perte d'autonomie et a
annoncé un dégel de 20 millions d'euros
pour le secteur de l'aide à domicile les
plus de 85 ans était un vrai que 4
millions en 2018 selon l'insee qui les
estime à 5 millions en 2060
le vieillissement de la population et
l'accompagnement des seniors est un réel
enjeu dans un objectif de maintien à
domicile des entreprises étendent leurs
activités habituelles d'aide-ménagère
reportage avec l'une d'entre elles à
plaisir une fois par semaine coraline se
rend chez madame jaussaud
oui c'est la femme de ménage elle est
employée par une agence spécialisée dans
l'aide à domicile ici sa mission est de
faire le ménage pendant deux heures
chaque mercredi matin j'ai vu vivant
pour la loge je suis obligé parce que je
ne peux pas tout faire non oui pour
lever les bras pour
que j'ai plus de difficulté mais plus
qu'une aide ménagère coraline se fait
aussi régulièrement offrir le café par
madame jaussaud elle le fait de passer
du temps avec eux de pouvoir aussi aux
portes de nos vies on trait vraiment un
lien avec les clients en plus du fait
qu'on leur apporte notre aide pour le
ménage si madame jaussaud est encore en
pleine forme pour faire sa cuisine et
ses courses ce n'est pas toujours le cas
des seniors qui peuvent tendre vers une
perte d'autonomie
forte de ce constat et du lien que nous
leur quarantaine de salariés avec leurs
clients seniors lagence plaisir was a
décidé d'étendre l'activité dettes
ménagères un réel accompagnement en
quatre axes alliés saveurs et nutrition
cultiver les liens intergénérationnels
prévenir les risques domestiques
enfin travailler sa mémoire et on est
vraiment sur une prise en charge globale
mais toujours en faisant ensemble et pas
à la place de puisque l'idée est
naturellement de préserver l'autonomie
des personnes âgées et aime bien qu'il
soit en perte d'autonomie progressive et
donc de les maintenir à leur domicile ce
qui est leur sourit l'agent selon cette
nouvelle prestation après deux ans
d'installation à plaisir et interviendra
également sur les communes de ville
prouver les clayes-sous-bois une manière
aussi de lutter contre l' isolement
selon le ministère des solidarités de la
santé 50 % des personnes de plus de 75
ans non plus des réseaux amical actif
depuis le début du mois le domaine de
dampierre change de visage après les
jardins c'est au tour du château
lui-même de retrouver une deuxième
jeunesse
l'échafaudage est en cours
d'installation deux ans de travaux sont
lancés principalement sur le logis la
partie centrale du château vont être
rénovés les chars pendant que les
lucarnes et encore les menuiseries des
précisions de pascal thévard directeur
général du domaine
nous allons bâché l'échafaudage il faut
évidemment protéger la couverture qui va
être enlevée donc du coup il ya un toit
qui va être mis sur cet échafaudage et
on va poser une bâche tout autour du
château puisque nous avons eu la chance
au mois de septembre de trouver dans les
greniers et bien des gravures anciennes
des façades du château de la fin du
xviie siècle et c'est ces éléments là
que nous allons mettre à l'échelle sur
le l'échafaudage et pour continuer
l'activité les équipes du château
proposeront durant l'été des visites
inédites un guide conférencier
présentera les travaux d'un module d'un
point de vue historique au public
côté sport on vous le présentez la
semaine dernière comme un espoir
yvelinois du rugby français fabien vite
ça a été titularisé en équipe de france
il va en face au pays de galles
le match a lieu ce vendredi 21 février
dans le cadre du troisième match du
tournoi des six nations
cet ancien pensionnaire de skyrock et
évolue désormais au racing 92 autres
jeunes sportifs à suivre ligny montrent
un evans peine les il a 16 ans et l'a
commencé à 8 ans dans une école de
karting parisienne et rêve de conduire
un jour une formule 1 en attendant une
partie de cette année à la porsche
carrera cup france qui fait notamment
l'ouverture des 24 heures du mans
il a déjà un joli palmarès troisième du
championnat d'europe en x30 junior et
11e dans le mondial il est intégré au
pôle espoir france du mans il expliquait
son envie de participer à la porsche
carrera cup sur le plateau du 7-8 sport
porsche c'est quelque chose que tout le
monde
tout le monde connait c'est s'aider
voiture l'a donc j'étais en monoplace
l'année dernière là on passa de là
j'étais complètement nue univers
complètement différent là la voiture
n'est pas la même donc donc voilà ça
change complètement et c'est porsche
c'est une grosse famille et donc voilà
très content de pouvoir participer à ce
championnat
le jeune pilote est en recherche de
financement et de partenariat vous
pouvez le contacter sus sur ces réseaux
sociaux au nom des vans nle enfin vous
en parle depuis plusieurs semaines la
fiche officielle vient de sortir le
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines va accueillir pour la première
fois de son histoire un match de
volleyball de première division
le clasico paris tour aura lieu le 28
mars prochain à 19h la billetterie est
ouverte et la rencontre sera suivie d'un
concert m'arrive à la fin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivi on se
quitte avec des images de l'exposition
consacrée au dessinateur de bd jacques
martin et son célèbre personnage
alix elle se tient actuellement à
l'espace richaud à versailles
et n'oubliez pas ce week-end sur tv soit
118 retrouvé une deuxième série de
débats pour les élections municipales ce
sera en direct
quant à moi je vous donne rendez vous
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]
et